how do you get folks on board the
correct way right and Bitcoin was
originally intended to be held in
self-custody right it wasn't it wasn't
made that was part of the beauty of the
Innovation is you can hold it yourself
in your own wallet you don't need a
third party custodian that's very tough
to do for a union to to kind of go oh
here's this thing I don't understand
let's put a bunch of money in that so
the key that I kind of started seeing
was hey I don't think any Union has ever
self-custody Bitcoin and what an amazing
way to start the Journey of learning by
learning about the fundamentals of
Bitcoin as a as a asset and a network
all right guys bang bang I've got Dom
here with me Dom you guys just made news
out in Santa Monica the Santa Monica uh
kind of fire Union and uh kind of the
entire region now is going and putting
Bitcoin on its balance sheet this is
different than the fire department doing
it it's different than the pension fund
doing it but it's the union help us
explain what is the union and why are
the firefighters all coming together to
make this decision
yeah so the firefighters Union you know
each department or or members of that
department have a union that's a a
chapter of a state union National Union
and uh in the case of Santa Monica it's
113 members that make up this Union uh
the step that occurred and there was a
long path to kind of get there
um was basically a one-time assessment
to explore Bitcoin uh not just as an
asset but as a network as a monetary
instrument as an innovation and take a
step to do that and so what occurred was
a very very small allocation one time to
self-custody bitcoin and that uh as far
as I know is the first time that a union
in the country has self-custody Bitcoin
others have purchased it held it on
their balance sheet Pension funds Etc
but not in this way
when you guys want to make the decision
walk me through
um does it come up in a meeting somebody
kind of makes a proposal is it just like
a wild idea why you guys are out
drinking one night like how does the
idea kind of first come up and then what
was the actual process when you
described that you went you actually
underwrote what is the asset what are
the monetary properties and what is the
innovation
so there's a there's a really long story
that I'll sum up quickly for the for the
show
um long story short you know I was first
exposed to Bitcoin in um well in 2011
everyone has that story where they they
weren't like listening and it's like
okay so that's one 2017
um I actually worked at this conference
um and learned a ton about that kind of
like the door got opened
um learned about Bitcoin always
understood uh the the value of Bitcoin
and what it meant and that it was the
first
um of course the long road after that
and then had what I call like a
re-orange pilling uh turn of events and
that's a long story but basically I was
working
and we had a rescue at work of an
analyst uh and it was leading up to
Pacific Bitcoin and I was once I was
working that and so we had this Rescue
of an individual from the Bitcoin
community and that kind of reopened my
my eyes and got me re I say an upped uh
dose of the orange pill from there wait
hold on hold on describe when you say
that you're rescuing a bitcoiner
describe uh kind of whatever detail you
can in terms of like their house is on
fire and you're like going into the
house to actually pull them out of the
house uh and then you're sitting on the
curb afterwards they're like hey by the
way do you know about Bitcoin or like
what what happened
so I was working with my crew at the
beach at the time
um it was the morning of like the FTX
news had broke so of course being the
bitcoiner I already am I'm coming in
like all right what is going on in in
this like all right you know Bitcoin is
down where it's not a question of like
uh if it's how and and what's the what's
the move and you know how how much are
we talking here so uh as that happens a
call goes off and uh it was for an
individual who was hurt at the beach and
we go to the beach there's an individual
kind of holding their neck they're just
sitting there and they had a dove in the
water and for those that don't know that
aren't from the West Coast or east coast
um you know you have a sand bar that
kind of goes like this it dips down and
then comes back up so potentially this
individual dove in what was deep water
into a shallow area hurt their neck
um you know that's one of those calls
where it seems like it's not a big deal
we packaged a person up we're going in
route I like to make conversation my
crew like unbelievable crew that they
you know they we took the precautions
and and we're going in route trying to
make small talk turns out this person's
an analyst uh um for a swan and um we're
talking and I'm like dude I'm working
you're an analyst first of all stop the
ambulance dude like like what's
happening right like where are we at
dude and I'm like I'm just kidding we're
laughing uh didn't stop the ambulance
but long story short uh he ended up
having a broken neck in two places and
when I ended up going to the conference
I was like I thought you know usually
you go Hey where's this guy at but you
know he'll be like thanks for sending me
to the hospital dude ruined my day and
like you know what up what a what if
Fiasco turned out he had a broken neck
and so
um that was just this crazy turn of
events where I got a lot more
um you know uh just involved in uh at
Pacific Bitcoin Swann was very
supportive and showed me tons of Love on
the journey and and that was kind of
like my start of exploration much deeper
into Bitcoin and then naturally having
10 years on the labor board and
finishing that that my two passions of
Bitcoin and labor union started coming
together and I started exploring that
intersection so and and and that that
led to this with the Santa Monica
firefighters got it and so when you guys
start to actually look at this uh and
the idea is proposed do people think
it's crazy or are they open to it like I
know the firefighter Community tends to
uh kind of think a little bit
differently
um given uh there's firefighter podcast
uh blue collar podcast there's I think
you guys have a podcast and just they
seem to be in and around these types of
Technologies or these types of movements
but what was the reaction when the idea
first came up
so having 10 years you know I've
navigated I was the president of our
Union so I know the system pretty well
I've navigated some challenging times
and done everything that we can imagine
in the books right so of course when it
comes to approaching a union like I have
a good background what I saw in working
through talking to other unions and
figuring out how do you onboard unions
and get them to learn about Bitcoin was
there's a lot of barriers many we talk
about you talk about on your show that
we know uh fear uncertainty doubt right
um
you know the things that have been
publicized heavily is to drop from
all-time highs to lows that gets
publicized Luna FTX publicized all this
like fear type things so I started
looking like how do you get folks on
board the correct way right and Bitcoin
was originally intended to be held in
self-custody right it wasn't it wasn't
made that was part of the beauty of the
Innovation is you can hold it yourself
in your own wallet you don't need a
third party custodian that's very tough
to do for a union to to kind of go oh
here's this thing I don't understand
let's put a bunch of money in that so
the key that I kind of started seeing
was hey I don't think any Union has ever
self-custody Bitcoin and what an amazing
way to start the Journey of learning by
learning about the fundamentals of
Bitcoin as a as a asset and a network
and so all you know I just approached
the board and there had been
conversation discussion on it and uh and
that that you know commitment was small
enough to be like let's just explore
this thing in a very exploratory fashion
and and then it kind of went to the
membership and the membership supported
it and that's how it happened so when
you talk about self-custody you bought
it on a platform you put it in
self-custody how did you guys get
comfortable with that right you know I
run uh Asset Management firms I run
businesses that have Bitcoin on their
balance sheet and whenever there is more
than just me as the owner or me as the
kind of participant uh there's always
the question of like hey do these other
people involved want me walking around
with a hardware wallet in my pocket with
basically our Bitcoin right same thing
here is that yes you plus 100 plus other
people have some sort of uh interest in
this Bitcoin
um how do you get comfortable
self-custody and how do you kind of deal
with the Dynamics there
yeah so a few ways one you know the
treasurer happened to be someone that
has been in the space themselves so they
had Comfort comfort with it so that was
a great thing The Treasure of any Union
board is kind of like uh the the manager
and overseer of the funds that Financial
you know that Union's finances
um the second thing again was making it
small enough of a dollar amount to where
the cost of mistakes failures learning
is extremely low and when I say a small
dollar amount like we're talking like
something that I believe most people
would be it'd be laughable right you're
like oh is this is this like a joke but
the thing is is there are a lot of
reasons why I think this route is
beneficial for groups unions
organizations
um and and we've seen some already just
now we did this prior to you know the
SEC uh pursuing finance and and uh and
coinbase and can you imagine if a union
put a thousand dollars is a person into
you know something they don't quite
grasp and you're seeing these headlines
of the SEC the the United States is is
now pursuing these exchanges and saying
what you're doing is not right you're
breaking the law wait what so it has to
be an amount to overcome a lot of these
hurdles price drops we know I mean you
know right like hey when you zoom out
Bitcoin is heading in this direction
when you zoom in it's a roller coaster
how do you overcome those drops it has
to be small enough to learn you cannot
put in more than your level of education
on it because it then it will not become
a thing that lasts it will become
something that ends fairly quick so
that's how we were going to come Comfort
level is that the amount is so
inconsequential that folks can be like
sure let's let's do self-custody let's
learn it that way and you can start that
learning have you guys publicized what
the numbers uh or you know how to say
we've sent it out it will come out but
but you know let's say not this let's
say forsake a conversation something
like you know a dollar per member right
some something that is like
um so minimal that again you're you're
not why would you do that not as an
asset to make money it's not going to
change your balance sheet and do that
but if you can learn about it for the
long run and set something up that's
more promising in the future and explore
make mistakes
um and then the value of that becomes
massive right because show me someone
that puts a few bucks into Bitcoin early
learns it doesn't get afraid and they go
in more and more versus someone who puts
10 million in but doesn't understand it
and they kind of freak out Panic sell it
move funds then zoom out 20 years and
show me who the who the winner is of
that
um I would argue that it's the person
that came in light yeah it's like it's
like a uh crawl before you walk before
you run type type strategy what is the
conversation like uh kind of in the
firehouse right so obviously this is
happening at the union level uh I'm
assuming some people agree with it some
people don't some people don't care like
what is the conversation been like
though
yeah you know that's another another
benefit with the inconsequential amount
is you get an overwhelming
um support which it was
um also remember for any organization
you're never going to get 100 support so
if you do this massive step and there's
you know 20 of the people are are not
into it they're gonna dig in deeper if
it really like impacts them and they're
like oh my gosh I have to now give this
money for this thing we're doing so by
doing that small step another benefit is
those people that were opposed to it are
still in a learning environment they're
still learning they still have an open
mind and so just again recently you know
conversation is good it's like hey the
way we hold it it's not on one of these
exchanges right I saw in the news the
SEC yeah exactly oh wow okay I get that
um understanding it like hey I notice
there's all this negative media but the
price of Bitcoin went down a little bit
and then up yeah yeah you know why is
that what are some of the other aspects
of it and so I think conversation is
really good which I think at the start
of any person or organization's Journey
you want that that good conversation
it's so interesting to hear you kind of
talk about this because you all are
basically the epitome of uh this concept
a couple years ago I started going
around saying get off zero right just
get off zero percent allocation and the
reason why I was doing it from uh kind
of institutional world was once they had
some skin in the game they would pay
attention that's basically what you're
saying here right is that like it
doesn't matter if it's a dollar a
hundred dollars a thousand dollars or
literally a hundred million dollars if
there's any amount of money into it
people will pay attention and now all of
a sudden you feel like
um there's academic studies that show uh
when you go to give uh a thing to
somebody if you give them a hundred
dollars or you give them a physical item
that's worth like let's say twenty
dollars usually they will put more value
on the item rather than the actual
economic value and so you could
literally say to someone hey do you want
this you want 100 bucks
um and so it's counterintuitive same
thing here though right is the amount
almost doesn't matter it's the fact that
now they all feel hey we as a union are
invested in this and therefore they pay
attention and you're really using it
sounds like a learning exercise and so
how do you take it from like the entry
point of learning to like where do you
want to go now right is it hey we want
to keep like dollar cost averaging in we
want everyone to become individual uh
kind of bitcoiners like how are you
thinking about it
well it's an excellent what you were
saying spot on with having skin in the
game you know I remember when I first
learned about stocks you know I I you
everyone starts with just a watcher
thing and you're like well what if I
invested in this and you're like I don't
care I forgot about it but if you put a
couple bucks you start checking that
thing and you go you know so
from here you know I think another
important thing about getting in at a
light level like this
we're gonna have a committee built which
is going to consist of internal folks
that understand Bitcoin
um you know the treasurer will be a
member and external folks who
um you know can help guide and and give
give good input um and from that
committee we can bring recommendations
different ideas but what you want is the
membership to drive the next step and if
that membership step is none and all we
did was learn there's value to that too
right because in 10 years 20 years
whatever Bitcoin becomes
we can at least say we took a look we
learned we understood it but I'll tell
you one thing about this small
allocation
the most common comment as this thing
was being voted on and supported was why
are we not doing more
great let's have that conversation but
let's understand you know the initial
answer is because it we don't understand
why we can't put more into something we
don't yet grasp
um but that the next steps you know
unions have all kinds of missions and
goals and things they want to do across
the world maybe someone to buy a union
hall one day and they can't afford a
piece of property so they start a trust
to one day put into it bit by bit using
it as a hybrid of a savings account but
also the fact that it's an asymmetrical
asset and they eventually get a piece of
property who knows maybe it's just a
trust for a health fund and they want to
be able to pay for medical insurance so
they set up a Bitcoin you know medical
trust there's all kinds of options but
now as you're learning about it as a
committee is kind of providing
information you're having these healthy
conversations the next step if the
membership decides they decide it will
be what is a model and goal to looks
good for us how are we going to move
into this it could just be more
allocation
um it could be something separate that
that's its own trust it could be
advocating for pension fund that we're
part of um to kind of like explore this
and and in five years look what it did
for us and so there's so many options
but it'll come from the membership
whereas previous examples of unions or
you know I'm sure you saw the headlines
there was a pension in Texas that went
in on you know years ago some of the
comments when our news thing came out
was like they're not the first to do it
um you know there's a pension fund in
Texas that did it well that was the fund
managers and that was a third party
custodian and I'm sure you know I don't
know what the level of understanding was
at the time this is much more bottom up
and that's where you want sustained long
the most successful long-term Pursuits
are bottom-up Grassroots where everyone
is on board and they can weather the
storm of things like negative media
attention price drop
um you know all kinds of stuff like that
what is the response been from other
unions or other types of organizations
where kind of people collectively come
together and they're trying to advocate
for certain interests right has there
been inbound and where those
conversations have they've been like
they're just tipping off got a lot of
good response you know one of the things
I'm working on and almost done with that
I'll probably put out on like a sub
stack for anyone who's a union member
organization person that wants to see
this is like uh almost like a blueprint
template of how to navigate this but
also you can customize it for your union
um and the response has been good though
because again the response has been a
hunger for more information right like
we're talking about like how do you guys
do it what what what did you guys get in
exactly
um and and that's the another benefit of
the small allocation is like wait wait
what did you guys do like you guys were
the first to do this but it's this small
amount and like and then and then do you
turn to your your ride and go hey Hey
Joe why are we not doing this this seems
like really non non-non or
inconsequential low risk like what's the
harm where's the harm great let's spur
that conversation because because I've
always been a Believer like don't don't
get involved in Bitcoin after you learn
about it that's fine but to just you
know read a headline or two and miss it
I mean you know we know this and you
have all kinds of people on your show
how many things have we missed in the
world by just reading the headline and
not digging in
um you know endless stuff where you just
look at it and then five years you hear
this great story and you're like oh my
God what was that like I wish I would
have looked at that at the time so that
I think I think there's good
conversation going around and sure
there's going to be people who are like
what you guys are doing that's stupid
um okay you know that's fine uh we'll
you know let's see how things play out
what is kind of your vision uh for the
next you know 12 months here is it
let's just see kind of what happens with
Bitcoin and just continue educating and
it's kind of almost hand to hand right
it sounds like like literally
conversations in the firehouse where you
guys are going to each other and you're
saying hey you know somebody asked a
question and you or somebody else who's
familiar with Bitcoin is there to answer
and kind of guide them in the right
direction is there anything else that
you're planning on doing over that
12-month period
no I I would say you know providing
information educating
um um working at a committee level to
provide different options and and again
truly
um going from a place of protecting the
membership that's another thing that's
really important you know um I care a
lot about all these folks that I work
with very much and I want to make sure
they're always in a good spot so so
being you know uh responsible educating
them and letting them kind of decide
what their next step is that's a good
place to be
um and I think we're in a good spot
additionally simultaneously this you
know I'm not on the board anymore so I
have to give all credit to the board and
the firefighters this is not like a me
thing this is something that through my
work and seeing how kind of Bitcoin and
unions in the workforce intersects
um you know was able to pit stop and
stop it at my own home Union and go look
I see this thing that's like very unique
and can be done by any Union as like a
very low risk way to just learn
it'd be great to work with other unions
and get them you know to a level of
comfort where they can take that step as
well
um and so I think I think within my
union they're going to be fine they're
they're sharp they're they're committed
they're going to learn and probably in
the next 12 months you know or as soon
as the next meeting there'll be more
conversation like what's next what's the
game plan let's learn reading lists
um info convo all the good stuff Tom
this is awesome uh congratulations to
you and the rest of the members it's
pretty cool to see uh again I love this
this strategy of like let's get off zero
let's do a small amount make it so that
if we make mistakes it's not going to
matter but also now people got to see in
the game they're gonna pay attention
they're going to get uh educated and I
think that driving education obviously
is the most important thing so uh
congrats to you and and everyone else
where can we send people to find you on
the internet if they want to learn more
if they want to reach out in terms of
they have a union or another
organization that they'd like to kind of
fall in your ass footsteps
yeah so uh Twitter you know obviously
Twitter's an active spot so my my handle
is Baywatch one again that has nothing
to do with the show my last name is bae
I wasn't the best student in high school
my basketball coach was my Spanish
teacher and he was like bae you're
messing up the teachers are watching you
they're on Baywatch so that kind of
stuck
um but yeah Twitter
um sub stack um I might have an article
coming out in Bitcoin mag which really
dives into Calpers and the pension and
how Bitcoin can can serve as a
stabilizer for pensions without much
risk as well
um explain what's going on there
yeah so so Calpers
um largest you know defined benefit
public pension in the United States they
got roughly 440 billion um on the books
uh in June of 2022 they had a funded
status of 72 percent this is something
for us that are in you know the labor
World we've seen many times but
the uh funded status of Labor of of
Pensions comes up frequently and so how
do these pensions that are chasing
workers living longer years retiring
later all these uh actuarials that get
factored in they don't have much
appetite for risk how can they
um you know stabilize their portfolio
without a bailout which is kind of like
what happens if it drops too low right
and they have to liquidate assets and
all that stuff
so this concept of a pre-funding a lot
of Pensions have these pre-funding
trusts which is basically almost like a
side fund to help fund what's called
unfunded liabilities uh and by involving
injecting Bitcoin at that level
uh they can keep all their Assets in
their main portfolio not switch anything
over to bitcoin and and pursue things
that way you also have this look what's
happening in California right you have
the state senate just passed a measures
uh advising they want to divest from
fossil fuels uh and Big Oil fossil fuels
and big oil are 10 of the portfolio 42
billion for Calpers where are they going
to go it's one of their best performing
assets what are they going to move into
commercial real estate we got some
issues coming up right like it's it's we
got some challenges so
um Bitcoin is this asymmetrical asset
that if they explore it outside of the
pension it can be used as a stabilizer
for the pension without taking much risk
you know of all the funds that are
involved
do you think there's headline risk with
them doing it
that the big risk is that they just
don't want to be the ones to do it
yeah headline risk regulatory risk all
kinds of risk you know but again there's
also risk in a fun and dropping to a
funded status of of 64 or sub 60 percent
and and kind of and kind of thinking
like all right like so they got risks
everywhere I'll tell you know but it
gets to the point where when you're
looking at it if there's no better
options to stabilize and catch up and
get to a funding status of over 80
percent 90 percent 100 percent
okay we might have to start taking some
headline risks um as long as the
headline in 10 years is you know Pension
funds stabilized through X Y and Z and
we're in a good spot then you know but
absolutely there's definitely headline
risk and fears for the same reasons even
at the at that micro level at the Union
why there's fears to kind of like take
that step
my last question for you is how many of
the firefighters do you think are
counting on their pensions like are they
still saying hey that's the thing I'm
going to retire on or have they now said
look maybe it's there maybe it's not but
I got to go kind of learn you know
Financial education in general and go
invest
I would say all of them
um you know some of them are much more
active in building things outside of
that but we're all you know when we all
signed up there was a a defined benefit
pension and firefighting you know like
any jobs there's trade-offs and one of
the things in this proof of Workforce
like concept I've I've been exploring is
and you know we trade time for money and
and this concept of trading time for
money we trade a lifetime we got
firefighters that get sick they die they
maybe don't live that long after
retirement it's a sacrifice for sure
don't get me wrong it's an incredible
career Amazing Life amazing Mission but
there are uh trade-offs and so you know
it's with this concept that you have a
pension that for those years after you
do your 30 years riding the fire engine
waking up every night you know doing CPR
running into fires you know on the
freeway at accidents
that's that's where that's where you're
going to be afterwards so I would say
all of them are depending on it in some
way of course there always are some that
kind of pursue things outside and get
like you know they're Building Wealth
like that but but definitely you know
dependent
Dom your pleasure to talk to man I I
love the fact that uh you have uh uh
specific expertise and knowledge and
obviously all of the jobs that you do on
a daily basis of firefighter you
understand Bitcoin very well and have
been able to uh kind of take your
knowledge there and integrate it uh with
uh the firefighting Union but also uh
your understanding of the Pension funds
and not just for the firefighters but
also you know asset allocation the
underfunded status
um and kind of how Bitcoin could
potentially be helpful there is pretty
incredible so uh it's obvious to me that
you spend a lot of time learning and
reading and stuff so I appreciate you
coming on here and sharing that
knowledge with us and we'll definitely
do it in the future
absolutely thanks Pop I appreciate it
and uh yeah man just uh we get after her
relentlessly brother